Data security is everybody's business.
There are a number of security solutions
out there. There are a number of security
products driving these security solutions.
And certainly, the security
teams are always inundated with
too many alerts, too many products,
and too many solutions to keep up with.
Data security is a constantly evolving and
a moving target. So when we talk about the
challenges of data security, it's all about having
an understanding of what data an organization has,
understand what are some of the compliance
mandates the organization needs to comply with.
And more importantly, be able to get to a
more proactive state where organizations are
managing and remediating security threats as they
arise. And that's really where Zero Trust light
frameworks come into picture. Zero Trust ensures
that you are verifying everything and not really
banking on trusting anything without verification.
Privacy and data security and governance are
interrelated. They are two phases
of the same coin in the sense that
privacy is something that you could drive with
having a robust data governance process and having
a very solid framework to enforce data governance
from a security point of view. And that's really
where data security solutions come in to play.
IBM believes the current state of data security
can be improved. We believe the market from here
goes towards more of an open and interconnected
space where security solutions could talk to
each other and essentially enable security
orchestration and response in a more congenial and
more homogenous way. And IBM Security solutions
are built using some of the security first
principles like separation of duties, being
able to deliver data-centric security controls
and ultimately drive all this in a way that is
enabling security teams to manage data security
threats and prioritize actions and remediation.
What that provides is the ability
for organizations to have their teams
across the board from compliance to privacy,
from risk management to applications,
infrastructure to operations, all come together
to address business challenges and particularly
data security threats and events in a more
collaborative way. My name is Rajesh Venkatasubbu,
product manager at IBM Security, and responsible
for data security and guardian data protection.